want to start by thanking the organizers
for inviting me to such an interesting
and diverse workshop i also want to
thank everybody in the audience for
coming back inside on a beautiful friday
summer afternoon you guys are the real
heroes um
okay so i'm going to be talking about
learning from noisy and incomplete data
my background is largely really entirely
in theoretical computer science
computational learning theory and
computational complexity so what i'll be
telling you will be sort of informed
from that perspective which is where i'm
coming from
let me start with kind of a cartoon
scenario which is a very crew
generalization of the kinds of
frameworks we'll be thinking about so
you can consider a setting in which you
have access to some labeled data points
so you can think of the x part as like
the example the data and the y part is
like the label and for this whole talk
we'll be dealing with classification
rules binary classifications so the y's
are always bits yeses and o's zeros and
ones you could imagine that maybe the
x's the j
x data point is the description of
weather conditions on some morning
gathered from some sensors or something
and maybe the y part is just a bit
indicating whether or not it ends up
raining that day or i don't know the x
uh could be something like a description
an encoding of some kind of molecule
you've cooked up in the lab and the y
tells us whether or not it has a
property that you're interested in okay
so it's a very general framework we can
imagine all kinds of
problems fitting into this and if we're
thinking about prediction for us that'll
mean essentially the following if i give
you a new data point so a t plus first
x example you'd like to be able to
correctly predict the label that goes
along with this point okay
and we'll be looking at these problems
from really a very sort of
theoretical computer science algorithms
and computational complexity perspective
we'll be trying to think about the
running time of algorithms that can
solve sort of well-specified problems of
this sort
okay so i should mention um going back
maybe to the uh
well i'll go ahead instead of going back
um i'll be talking mostly about a very
clean i think an elegant theoretical
model of learning solving learning
problems of this sort that's the
so-called pac learning or probably
approximately correct learning model i'm
going to give you really a survey talk
so i won't brutalize you with anything
extremely technical or detailed this
afternoon instead i'll just sort of
tell you about the state of the art and
some upper bounds so efficient
algorithms for solving learning problems
in this framework and some lower bounds
hardness results or results which
indicate that we shouldn't expect to
have efficient algorithms for other
problems
of course we're going to be concerned
with like i promised in the title
learning with noise and learning from
partial information so the original pac
learning model doesn't have these
qualities it really is sort of a very
idealized way of thinking about learning
problems but there have been extensions
of the model and people now you know
kind of intensively study these
questions of how can we deal with noise
how can we deal with scenarios where we
don't have all the information we would
want to have and so on
so if i get time at the end i hope to
touch a little bit also on some
unsupervised learning problems so i
haven't used the phrase yet but
you know the sort of framework i've been
talking about where you have x and f of
x you have a label associated with each
example is of course supervised learning
i'll also hopefully get to talk a little
bit about unsupervised learning problems
and the framework here will be a
framework of learning probability
distributions or you could think of it
as density estimation as a phrase that's
sometimes used in statistics and there's
been some recent work here as well on
trying to handle noise trying to handle
partial information for learning
problems of this sort okay so kind of a
road map
of where we'll be going
okay before i get into details and
really tell you what the model is let me
give you um kind of a little bit of high
level setup or motivation or intuition
as i said earlier we'll be thinking of
setting where we get these examples x
and then we have a label for the example
which is y
the examples we'll think of is really
just a vector of feature values so i'll
sometimes use this term a feature to
mean one of the coordinates of the
example x we'll always think of x as
being a vector typically a real vector
or a boolean vector if we have
categorical data so maybe an example
corresponds to a patient in a database
and we have different coordinates of the
vector describing that patient the
height the weight so on and so forth and
the label would be something like
whether or not this patient responded
well maybe to a particular treatment
so the algorithmic kind of problem the
general template for the problems we'll
be thinking about is we have a data set
of labeled examples so we have a bunch
of
data points like this the example in the
label and we'd like to come up with a
hypothesis a binary classification rule
which will do a good job of assigning
the correct label to future unlabeled
examples that we might receive and we'll
make this framework more precise in a
minute
to touch briefly though on the
properties of the idealized scenario
this original so-called probably
approximately correct learning model
which will eventually extend
in the idealized you know original model
we make some assumptions
the first of these is sort of central to
this complexity theoretic or theoretical
computer science view on the problem
which is that we're going to really be
thinking about function classes as sort
of defining or learning problems right
we'll be in sort of a very well
specified setup where there's always
going to be some unknown rule that
correctly labels the examples that we
have to deal with i'll talk much more
about this later
in the basic scenario as well we're
going to assume we don't have missing
data so i actually know what all the
coordinates are for every data point i'm
dealing with and in the idealized
scenario we won't have noise but again
we'll relax these assumptions as we go
further through the talk
okay and here's just sort of a crude
example of um maybe the true unknown
rule that we're trying to learn is
defined by a linear separator like the
stashed gray line and the learning
algorithm if it's supposed to come up
with a high accuracy hypothesis maybe
successfully comes up with something
like this black line right which is
fairly close in some sense to the
unknown
true classification rule
okay so as i said we're going to be sort
of thinking of learning problems as
corresponding to classes of functions
classes of classification rules okay so
let me be a little bit more precise
about this for us a learning problem
will be defined by a class this bold
face c of boolean valued functions over
some domain x so this bold x that's
where the examples come from it's maybe
bit strings of length n or vectors of
unreal numbers something like that
that's what an unlabeled example looks
like for us an element of this set
okay what we'd like to do is learn some
unknown target function i'll always
write f for that it belongs to this
class c but we don't know what it is
okay that's sort of the whole challenge
what does it mean to learn it means
we're going to come up with a hypothesis
function which hopefully is close to
this target function f in some sense
okay so i'll get into more detail on
exactly what this means in the coming
slides but first let me give you some
examples of the types of classes of
functions we might think about again
from a cs theory background
logically defined formulas where we're
sort of interested in how does the
complexity of learning scale with the
complexity of the functions being
learned that's sort of our central
concern so we'll be thinking about
classes sort of like this starting small
we might think about the class of all
possible conjunctions of literals over n
boolean variables so a conjunction is
just a simple and right here's an
example of a conjunction and this class
of all conjunctions over n variables has
three to the n elements right because
for each of the n variables it might be
absent from the conjunction it might be
present unnegated or it might be present
in a negated form so three possibilities
for each of the n variables right so
first thing to notice is even for the
simplest learning problems we might
think about there are exponentially many
possible functions in the class so we
have a non-trivial problem to try to do
learning here
okay another class which is very uh
widely studied and it's kind of you know
works workhorse in this area is the
classical linear threshold functions
these have many names linear separators
perceptrons of order one half spaces
people call them lots of different
things but here it just corresponds to
you take the sine of a linear form you
look at where your point is in euclidean
space and if it's on this side of the
hyperplane it's a positive example if
it's on this side of the hyperplane it's
a negative example okay so we'll come
back to these uh more later
some other classes of functions that
people think about again these have you
know strong motivation maybe from a
complexity theoretic perspective one
example would be the class of all
decision trees over boolean variables
right so a decision tree like this we
you know read a variable the variable at
the root we always go left if we see a
zero and right if we see a one or left
if we see false right if we see true and
then just reading the input coordinate
by coordinate we make our way down to
some leaf bit which gives us the label
okay so we might want to have a system
which can efficiently learn an unknown
decision tree like this right assuming
the decision tree isn't too large if we
have n variables maybe we want to learn
polynomial size decision trees with an
efficient algorithm
a richer class is the class of dnf
formulas these are just ors of logical
ands
and you know the list goes on you can
imagine really
all kinds of classes of boolean circuits
maybe with even richer structure than an
auravans functions of linear threshold
functions etc etc so kind of one of the
big names of the game in this area again
is as you go from simpler kinds of
classes things like this and this
to more complicated kinds of classes
where is sort of the boundary between
tractability and intractability for
learning right at what point do we are
we no longer able to learn these
functions and you know can we push it as
far as we can
okay
so i'd better actually tell you what the
learning model is um basically we should
think of a learning model as just kind
of specifying the rules of the game how
does the learning algorithm get the data
what kind of access to the data does it
have and what is it supposed to do what
is it supposed to accomplish with its
hypothesis
so people have studied a you know wide
array of different learning models over
the years i kind of don't want you to
read the fine print here it's just to
get across
that impression that there are many
different ways you can define a learning
model
we're going to stick to at least
originally this first probably
approximately correct model later on as
i said we'll augment it by thinking
about what happens if we have noise what
happens if we have missing data okay
okay so let me actually tell you what
the basic model is again it's the
so-called probably approximately correct
model it's sometimes called distribution
independent learning because as we'll
see it's a framework where the learning
algorithm is supposed to succeed
independent of what the distribution is
okay it should always be able to handle
any distribution over examples
so how does it work like i said we think
of a learning problem as being defined
by a class of functions okay so this
class of functions this bold c is fixed
and the learner knows what it is the
learner knows hey i'm trying to learn a
conjunction i'm trying to learn you know
a polynomial size decision tree okay
however the target function as we said
is not known to the learner it belongs
to the class so we get to assume yeah
i'm trying to learn it's actually some
conjunction the thing i'm trying to
learn but of course you don't know what
conjunction it is
okay
there's an unknown and completely
arbitrary distribution over the domain
this is meant to model the idea that you
know the world
is what it is and we don't really maybe
have that much knowledge or that much
control over what the world is but we
should try to deal with it anyway so
there's an unknown distribution over the
domain what does the learner get the
learner gets a sample of iid draws from
this distribution so it gets a bunch of
xy pairs where each x is drawn
independently from the distribution and
each y is just f of x labeled according
to the unknown target function
the learner does some computation cooks
up a hypothesis and spits it out and
what does it mean to succeed it means
the learning algorithm should have come
up with a hypothesis which with high
confidence with small failure
probability with probability one minus
delta is highly accurate so that means
that the probability over a fresh random
example drawn from the distribution the
probability that the hypothesis agrees
with the correct label is at least one
minus epsilon okay so it's sort of this
natural epsilon delta criterion
again our hypothesis should probably
with probability one minus delta be
approximately correct right have
probability 1 minus epsilon of giving us
the right label
okay so we can give a formal definition
here if you want to read through it
we're interested in learning a class of
function c and some time bound t that
means that no matter what the target
function is no matter what the
distribution is if you come to me with
epsilon and delta the accuracy and
confidence you'd like to achieve my
algorithm should run for most t time
steps t might depend on epsilon and
delta of course and with probability one
minus delta i should get an epsilon
accurate hypothesis out
okay
so i think it's a pretty natural model
uh you can see that it really sort of
faithfully captures the intuition i
think behind training and testing and
machine learning if you train your
classifier on a certain type of data a
reasonable way to see how well your
learning system has worked is to
evaluate it on similar data points data
points that came from the same sort of
process as you train the original thing
on
and again we'll be sort of centrally
concerned with computational efficiency
with the running time of learning
algorithms
very well known results which are
covered in the first few weeks of
probably any learning theory or machine
learning course tell us that if you're
only worried about sample complexity if
you only want to know hey how many
examples do i need in order to learn in
this sense
the answer to that question is really
generally pretty easy for every class
i'll be talking about
you can learn with a polynomial number
of samples you can learn you can learn
efficiently in terms of the number of
examples you need but the running time
the computational complexity of learning
is a whole different story right
sometimes we have efficient algorithms
sometimes we don't have efficient
algorithms so it's all going to be about
running time for us question yeah what
distribution is
good question so that probability is
taken over the draw of the random
examples that were the data set the
training set for the learner
i don't think i don't think i said this
but i should have so the reason we need
that sort of one minus delta failure
probability is because it could be the
case that when you were getting your
training set you were just unlucky you
got sort of very atypical examples which
really didn't faithfully show you what
the underlying distribution is like
so that that probability is over um you
could say like d to the m like the
product distribution of you know if you
have m sample points it's over that
space it's over the draw of the samples
does that answer sure yeah okay i seem
to recall seeing a variant that may have
wrongly been labeled back where the
epsilon is used as the approximation of
h to f so h minus f
so this is yeah this is the same thing
we're doing here um here these are both
these are boolean valued functions and
so this is like the error this is the
accuracy the probability that they agree
on a random draw
yeah yeah not necessarily over a point
so since we're doing since we're in a
setting where these are just in these
are just bits h and x um i think it's
it's equivalent if you're in a
regression type setting and there are
regression variants right then you can
then you can look at uh yeah something
more sophisticated
okay
so let me quickly survey for you
something of what we know the state of
the art for efficient learning
algorithms in this framework
unfortunately this is only going to
amount to one slide because we don't
know all that much
so when the model was originally defined
valiant showed that uh
certain restricted classes of dnf
formulas or bands or cnf formulas and
zevors can be learned efficiently right
if your bottom fan in your bottom fan
and gates are constantarity rdk for some
constant then you have polynomial time
algorithms that run in time essentially
into the k and it's a simple algorithm
sometimes referred to as elimination
not too long after that revest gave a
simple polynomial time algorithm for
learning decision lists right these are
sort of nested if-then-else rules if the
first
variable if the first condition is
satisfied you output one otherwise you
go on and check the second condition if
that's satisfied you're output zero so
on and so forth so there's a simple
greedy algorithm which runs in
polynomial time to learn this
as i kind of suggested earlier linear
threshold functions this is a very
important class in learning theory
these can be learned in polynomial time
via polynomial time linear programming
and also a generalization to not just
linear threshold functions where we have
a linear decision surface but polynomial
threshold functions this is my attempt
to draw something like a degree 3 or
degree 4 curve
if you have a degree d polynomial
threshold function is the underlying
function then you can learn in time n to
the d really just by using the linear
programming type approach but over
into the d variables or meta variables
so this is uh this is really kind of
one of the main tools in pac learning
theory we'll come back to it again later
and a handful of other pac learning
results are known for different classes
you can learn like parity functions
using essentially gaussian elimination
you can learn some extremely restricted
types of branching programs these are
branching programs of width at most too
with other constraints on them some
geometric function classes
unfortunately this is about it not much
more than what's up on this slide or
constitute the entire
collection of function classes that
people have been interested in and have
been able to show pack learnable on the
original model so that's kind of tough
right learning is not so easy in this
framework
um
given this challenge people have said
okay you know maybe i'll relax my
standards a little bit someone talked
earlier in this workshop about
redefining the problem when we have
trouble solving the problem right so
maybe we'll we'll be interested still in
uh
more than polynomial time algorithms but
algorithms which are faster than some
kind of brute force search running in
time significantly better than two to
the n so quasi-polynomial time would be
maybe n to the log n
exponential times maybe 2 to the square
root n something like that and a handful
of results are known here it's known
that you can learn
decision trees in quasi-polynomial time
you can learn dnf formulas in
sub-exponential time you can learn
various
kind of restricted classes where you
combine a few half spaces if your half
spaces have small integer coordinates
you can do something like this
and for all these results i don't want
to get into any details on this but
linear programming over an expanded
feature space is really the key
technique that underlies each of these
results most of the work is to prove
some kind of structural result saying
hey you know my intersection of half
spaces has a low degree polynomial
threshold function representation right
so you sort of think like a complexity
theorist prove something about the
structure of the functions and then we
just use the same old algorithm to learn
polynomial threshold functions this
really is the state of the art
okay unfortunately not only is there not
that much good news but there's some
very strong bad news in this framework
too okay we have a range of negative
results from cryptography and from other
areas telling us about limitations on
pac learning that we shouldn't expect to
learn certain classes in small amounts
of time
so
i don't really want to go through all
these things individually in a lot of
detail because i want to get to the
noisy and
you know missing data part of the talk
but
the existence of
public key cryptography where the
decryption function under various number
theoretic assumptions is believed to be
not so hard to compute tells us that we
shouldn't expect to learn for example
polynomial size boolean formulas even
more restricted classes if you look at
the specific constructions of
pseudorandom functions which are
believed to be secure in the literature
tell us we shouldn't expect to learn
weaker classes and even a class of
fairly simple depth two circuits
intersections of linear threshold
functions
uh regeth came up with the cryptosystem
about 10 years ago which nobody's
cracked yet and if you believe that that
cryptosystem is indeed secure you won't
even be able to learn this class
efficiently
distribution
negative results so if i just say this
class is not packed learnable what does
it mean it means there
uh there is no algorithm which works for
all distributions however for each of
these cases you can actually
if you look at what's really going on
you have hardness at least for the first
two i'm not sure about the third one you
actually have hardness even against just
the uniform distribution even against
very simple distributions yeah
so more recently there's been other
exciting work yeah
i i think that's something i could show
you repeat once more so so and it's the
dimension of the of the vectors you're
getting exactly so each example is like
the training set
the results do people do
are these asymptotic inside of the
training set or
it can't work with the training set of
size one so
so these results say you pick your
favorite polynomial bound on the size of
the training set and squared and to the
fifth then to the 100 these results tell
you there's no algorithm which can learn
say
uh this class of functions if you give
it a training set of size n to the 100
or whatever polynomial size training set
you want to give it so what those polly
does referring to the sites of the
training set or the time it takes to run
the yeah
sorry yeah if when you see poly here or
poly here think of it as some fixed
polynomial n squared right or
yeah so there's no there's no
let me maybe rephrase this this bullet a
little bit more precisely
uh it says that there is no algorithm
which runs in polynomial time you can
give it a polynomial size training set
so you know for for
n squared and to the fifth and to the
tenth and to the one hundred there's no
algorithm which takes a training set of
that size runs in that much time
okay and learns here you could say the
class of depth five circuits
of um linear threshold function gates of
size n squared you might have something
which takes polyurethane training
samples and runs an exponential timer
yeah for every class that i'm talking
about in this entire talk there's always
a learning algorithm which takes a
polynomial size training set and runs in
exponential time yeah the sample
complexity the information theoretic
question is not a very difficult one
it's all about the computational
complexity for this work yeah
yeah good question
okay so i'll be very brief on this slide
because i want to get to the other stuff
uh there are more recent sort of average
case hardness assumptions an assumption
having to do with uh the time complexity
of refuting random cnf formulas
and uh danielle and shell of schwartz
has shown that if you're willing to make
the assumption that we don't have fast
refutation algorithms for these random
cnf formulas then some really simple
classes seem like they are indeed going
to be hard to learn we're not going to
be able to learn dnf even with a you
know mildly super constant number of
terms we're not going to be able to
learn intersections of you know even
just a little bit more than
uh log in many have spaces and so on
so this is strong bad news right this
talk has been a real downer so far all
i've been doing is telling you you know
this is probably not learnable we don't
know how to learn that so on and so
forth pac learning looks pretty tough
and to make things worse i haven't even
mentioned noise yet right this hopefully
we're going to do something about
learning in the presence of noise
learning with missing data that's only
going to make things harder right so how
are we possibly going to cope with this
situation
well we're going to do the classic
theorists dodge of changing the goal
posts trying to solve some different or
in some sense easier problem but before
i get to the you know part about making
it easier let me tell you a little bit
about what i mean by noise for the rest
of this talk
so there are some noise models which are
so you know challenging and annoying
that it would just depress me and
depress you for me to talk about them
i'm not going to talk about those
instead i want to mention this i think
still quite interesting noise model
known as agnostic learning which is
about 20 years old now so the way we'll
model noise is we're going to say you
know i no longer am assuming that the
function i'm trying to learn necessarily
belongs to this particular class c the
function now can be arbitrary and you
can think of the deviations of this
function f right from the functions in
the class as being like the noise the
sense in which it no longer is
faithfully um
like in this nice clean scenario
so there's this very natural notion then
this parameter opt opt is defined
relative to your class c and your
distribution d what is it it's sort of
the minimum distance
of any function in the class to the
target function to the function f
right so if your function f is actually
in the class opt is zero
right because you're actually in the
class there's no distance but maybe you
know if your class is the class of all
linear threshold functions maybe the
best linear threshold function is such
that it only agrees with the target
function 90 of the time in a setting
like that opt would be 0.1
okay
so the agnostic learning model says hey
i'm not assuming my function f belongs
to the class it could be arbitrary but
i'm also saying you know i don't have to
learn the function to super high
accuracy instead i just want to
construct a hypothesis whose error rate
is at most opt plus epsilon or you know
sometimes that's going to be rough maybe
we'll still be interested if we can
achieve you know three times opt plus
epsilon 10 opt plus epsilon or even
something like square root up to plus
epsilon okay so we call it agnostic
learning if we can really get opt plus
epsilon which corresponds to having our
hypothesis predict the value of the
function really almost as well with an
epsilon accuracy as well as the best
function in the class and if we can get
something like you know five up plus
epsilon square root of plus epsilon we
call that quasi-agnostic learning okay
so not as good but you know still good
for something
so it won't be a surprise we said
earlier pac learning is hard if you
introduce noise go to this agnostic
model things only get harder even simple
classes which we could learn in the
original pac framework like linear
threshold functions or half spaces even
conjunctions we cannot learn in the
agnostic model
okay so what are we going to do well
we're going to change
the goal posts like i said right what
i've been talking about so far this pac
learning model we have that the
distribution d is unknown it's an
arbitrary distribution and that really
means for the purposes of analysis it's
adversarial we have to deal with the
worst possible distribution that anyone
might have cooked up right we're going
to relax this we're going to change the
game and say you know i'm going to
assume that the distribution is
something that i know what it is and in
fact i'm going to assume that the
distribution is nice in some sense so
kind of the standard assumptions that
are the subject of a lot of work here
are that if we're dealing with say
binary data where our data points are
examples or n-bit strings then the
standard assumption is that the
distribution maybe is just the uniform
distribution over n-bit strings or maybe
it's a product distribution where we
have independence among coordinates
if the domain is rn if we have vectors
of real numbers as our sort of labeled
as our examples uh then we'll typically
assume that the distribution is just a
standard gaussian distribution or maybe
a non-standard gaussian distribution but
so the name of the game is that we're
relaxing the assumption
on noise we're in this agnostic setting
now but we assume more about the the
data in the sense of the distribution so
we sort of let go of some control or
some assumed control over the labels and
we assume more about the examples
themselves
okay
so what happens in this setting what can
we say
uh turns out there are a bunch of things
that can be said here um first i'll i'll
sort of survey briefly some actual
agnostic learning results where we can
really achieve opt epsilon as good as
you could hope to do
so in work about 10 years ago it was
shown that one can learn linear
threshold functions in something like
polynomial time here if you're willing
to think of the epsilon parameter as a
constant
then this is n to the one over epsilon
squared it's a high order polynomial but
it is some kind of polynomial time
and the technique that was introduced in
this work really is
at the heart of all of the agnostic
results i'll tell you about it's a kind
of l1 polynomial regression algorithm
which reduces the agnostic learning
problem to the problem of designing
low-degree polynomial approximators so
all of the later agnostic learning
results i'll tell you about were really
achieved by using this technique and
doing complexity theoretic work of
showing hey these functions that i'm
interested in i can approximate them in
a suitable sense by low-degree
polynomials
so one example of such work is work on
learning intersections of several half
spaces right we have only a relatively
mild dependence on the number of half
spaces it's logarithmic although it is
in the exponent and these gaussian
surface area bounds are sort of what
underlies the
existence of these low-degree polynomial
approximators
similar results have been achieved for
learning low-degree polynomial threshold
functions so when we have these degree d
surfaces you can similarly do something
again by proving gaussian surface area
bounds
but it's not all roses right we do have
some limitations on what we know we can
achieve here in particular it's been
shown that we should not expect to have
really polynomial time algorithms
polynomial in n and one over epsilon
right this lower bound was given which
shows that even for this sort of very
clean and simple problem learning one
linear separator under the gaussian
distribution you're not going to be able
to get up to plus epsilon under some
assumption about the hardness of
learning
sparse noisy parity functions okay so
there's a lot of room though between
this n to the one over epsilon squared
and this end to the log one over epsilon
would be very interesting to understand
more precisely what is the real um what
is the real complexity there
so this is all under the gaussian
distribution which in some sense i think
is really the easiest non-trivial
distribution for learning you have this
radial symmetry really is just about as
nice as things can be
if we are willing to lower our standards
and think about just quasi-agnostic
learning it turns out that you can
sometimes do significantly faster
so in the same early work it was shown
that you can achieve something just not
that much worse than opt opt times
square root log one over opt so not you
know that that much this additional
factor the square root log one over opt
we wish it were one but it's probably
not that tremendous a number and this is
truly polynomial time in fact the
algorithm here runs in linear time in
the in the length of the data you just
read it and i don't want to use the word
real time after everything we've seen
this week but it's it's really a very
simple linear time algorithm
this was improved at the expense of some
more running time so you can learn to
accuracy five op plus epsilon or ten opt
plus epsilon in polynomial time and uh
quite recently it was shown how you can
really get like a polynomial time
approximation scheme you want 1.01 times
off plus epsilon you can achieve it but
you're going to sort of pay for it in
the exponent so this result really kind
of interpolates between the results we
saw before
and
you know this the simplest and fastest
result on top
okay
so i don't want to go into great detail
on these results these are results for
agnostic and quasi-agnostic learning
under the uniform distribution on the
cube the cube is harder than the sphere
you have less symmetry things aren't
quite as nice you know your half spaces
can sort of lie arbitrarily close to
some points which is sort of obnoxious
but you know by dint of complexity
theoretic work people have been able to
sort of almost match the kinds of
results we saw for the gaussian
distribution
in the setting of the cube
and there's really only one result i
know of on quasi-agnostic learning
learning to accuracy worse than not plus
epsilon um
in the setting of the cube this is work
which achieves this really rather ugly
i'm afraid
dependence again we'd like to have opt
here what we have here is worse than
square root of opt it's worse than opt
to the 0.1 but it's some kind of
dependence at least it depends only on
opt right if we had a dependence on n or
something the dimension of the problem
then we wouldn't really think of that as
agnostic or quasi-agnostic learning
anymore
but this is at least a fairly fast
algorithm it's not quite polynomial in
epsilon but it's again it's really uh
linear in the number of bits you have to
read information theoretically you need
n
n-bit strings and the the running time
i'm showing you here is bit complexity
so it's it's linear in terms of sort of
the bit complexity but unfortunately you
need quasi-polynomial amount of data in
terms of the dependence on epsilon
and actually the algorithm for this
comes from
learning from incomplete information the
next topic which i promised you which i
want to turn to at this point
so we've talked so far entirely about
settings where we're learning
from you know these n-dimensional
vectors that's our example and then we
have a binary label and we've always
been assuming that you get the entire
n-dimensional vector as your example
each data point you can see every
coordinate right but in fact that's
sometimes an extremely unrealistic
assumption the truth of the matter might
be much closer to the opposite than in a
typical data point you get you really
can see almost none of the n coordinates
as opposed to being able to see all of
them think about like a medical scenario
or something maybe you have a different
feature for every possible
diagnostic test you might run on the
patient or every possible treatment you
write run on the patient you're not
going to subject the patient you know to
100 different treatments you're probably
not going to run 100 different
diagnostic tests on the patient you
might run two or three tests you might
give them one treatment or two
treatments and then you see how they
respond so your label data point will
only have one or two coordinates out of
all the sort of possible coordinates
right so it's very much not like this
idealized setting we've been talking
about
but it's interesting of course to study
can we say something can we give some
theoretical guarantee on learning in a
setting like this where we have very
little available data
within each data point
so this has indeed been studied it's
sometimes referred to as this restricted
focus of attention or rfa learning model
i'll explain it to you in this slide
as before we're trying to learn an
unknown function f from this class c of
known functions as before we have a
distribution over possible examples but
what really changes is that now
if it's the so-called one rfa model
which is the most intensively studied
model the learner doesn't see all n
coordinates of any given data point
instead the learner only sees one
coordinate of the data point okay so in
the usual scenario we would get to see
the entire nbit string and then the
label in this one rfa learning scenario
you get to see one of the n coordinates
as well as the label so much much less
information is available to the learning
algorithm
okay but we want to do the same thing we
were trying to do earlier come up with a
high accuracy hypothesis h with high
confidence okay so kind of a cartoon of
how learning proceeds in this model we
have the learner we have the source of
data the learner says you know i'd like
an example and please make it an x7
example show me the seventh bit so it
gets back something like this the
learner says yeah you know i really
could stand to learn more about what's
going on here about the seventh
coordinate please show me another x7
example and it gets back something like
this now maybe this time the seventh
coordinate is zero the label is one so
on and so forth and at the end of the
day the learner has to spit out some
high accuracy hypothesis based on this
kind of uh
interaction
so what can we say well we can say some
bad news of course right it's very easy
to see that if your distribution is
unknown and arbitrary it's almost
impossible to do anything in this
framework right
yeah yeah
in pac-learning the
learner
can't specify anything about the
examples yeah
here you're allowing the learner to
specify something about it yeah so
strictly speaking the way i've presented
it the learner does get to do the
specification probably the first thing
one always does in studying this model
is say you know what does the learner
really have it just has statistical
information about the correlation
between this coordinate and the label
right and it has that kind of
information for each of the end
coordinates so that's that's another
that's another way of specifying the
model yeah so basically the examples of
it being drawn from the overall
underlying distribution has been
projected onto this exactly exactly you
get to see the one-dimensional marginal
of the n-dimensional
this kind of access uh already in sort
of the pack setting
so that's exactly that's exactly what
this does right this is just like the
packed setting but where you only have
this kind of access
you could also
allow the learner to influence the x on
which it gets
an answer
um
do you mean like i'm not quite sure what
you mean so here you get to i mean when
the learner presents and an x and gets
the
learner is pr the learner is given an x
the learner doesn't actively select an x
yeah
what happens when you change the model
and you allow the learner to choose
which
good so that's pac learning with
membership queries is the buzzword
there's a whole other talk with a
different set of results some things
become significantly easier some things
don't become so much easier some of the
hardness results still hold some of them
don't still hold so it's just a
different ballgame yeah yeah but in
practice
my impression is
people will sometimes say you know it's
really not so easy to
have that kind of access right so people
have done experiments where they try to
run these like membership query learning
algorithms on say recognizing
handwritten data and the algorithm
starts very quickly asking for these
bizarre pseudo digits which look like
some kind of
you know is this a two or is this a
three and like we don't know how to
label it then so yeah this kind of this
kind of thing i think is maybe it's a
little bit more difficult to put that in
the context of
real systems
but
okay
good so
this is a hard model if the distribution
can be arbitrary basically how are you
going to tell this function and this
distribution from this other function in
this other distribution you just don't
have access to enough information from
these you know very restricted views to
be able to tell things apart
even if your distribution is as nice as
it gets even if your distribution is
uniform over n-bit strings
it's information theoretically
impossible it's easy to see this to
learn sort of functions where you have
non-trivial
associations i don't want to define this
precisely but maybe the example makes it
clear suppose your unknown target is the
parody of two
variables so it's some xi xor xj that's
the target function but you don't know
which
what what variables i and j are it's
easy to see that in this framework it's
completely impossible to learn right
because you only ever get to see one bit
of any example so you know you're just
never going to see any correlation
between any bit and the label
there's no chance of learning here
so can we do anything well it turns out
we can do something for the right
function classes so it comes back again
to these linear threshold functions the
class we'll think about again is all n
variable linear threshold functions
we'll think about this nice distribution
uniform over the cube so this is a paper
from i think either the very first or
the second fox conference chao
showed that if you get two to the n
examples like this again the example is
always just this bit and this this bit
in the label this bit in the label right
but if you have access to i mean this
gives you such good statistical
information that you really know exactly
the value of the correlation under the
uniform distribution between each
coordinate and the label another way of
putting it is that you know the exact
values that you know the exact values of
the degree one fourier coefficients of
the function if you know that that is
enough information information
theoretically to learn to perfect
accuracy so another phrasing of this
chao result is that the degree zero and
degree one fourier coefficients of a
linear threshold function uniquely
specify it actually among the space of
all boolean functions
okay and there's some very cute proofs
of this in sort of modern language
uh of course we want to do something
faster than two to the end time and we
want to you know we're willing to give
up some accuracy is there a robust
version of this theorem so it turns out
there is a robust version of this
theorem if you want to learn to say just
some small constant accuracy then
something like polynomial n and 2 to the
one over epsilon squared examples
suffices for that
and people worked more on this and were
able to actually come up with algorithms
which could do quite well for this
problem so again this is the algorithm i
referred to earlier it runs in linear
time in the
in the bit length of the entire data set
that it has to use and it's not quite
polynomial in in terms of the accuracy
parameter but it's uh
it's it's fairly close um and there's
some hope still of maybe being able to
improve it
so this is something which we do know
how to do um in the one rfa model i
think it would be very interesting and
as far as i can tell it's completely
unexplored to go beyond one
right so okay you get to see one bit
of the data that's really about as
pessimistic as it gets right what if i
show you two bits what if i'm willing to
show you i don't know log one of our
epsilon bits or one over epsilon bits or
something i think there's you know this
is really one point on on the curve you
see the minimal possible amount of data
we understand what happens if you get to
see all n bits but there's a lot of
space in the middle and i think there
may be an opportunity for some
interesting results sort of to trace
that curve if we can understand more of
what's going on
um okay looks like i'm just about
well not quite out of time i have maybe
two or three minutes left but
do you guys want to see something
quickly but unsupervised learning
sure okay
so this is a framework it's sort of
cooked up by design to be similar in
spirit to this pack learning model
except that there are no functions there
are no labels anymore okay we're going
to be in a setting where we just want to
somehow extract some meaningful
information
from a scenario where we just don't have
access to any kinds of labels about the
data at all so this is a model that was
introduced at least into theoretical
computer science about 20 years ago by
ranit and some colleagues
things like this have been studied in
statistics really for decades though
under the name of density estimation it
really is just like pac learning like if
you were to you know guess what the
model should be
and you just said pac learning but with
no functions you would you would come up
with the right model so how does it work
learning problems now we're going to be
defined by a class of possible target
distributions for us okay so no
functions just the unknown distribution
plays the role of the unknown function
okay so the target distribution belongs
to this class but we don't know what it
is we know that it belongs to this class
we know the class but we don't know
which guy it is from the class the
learner gets an id sample of draws from
the distribution again no functions so
just x
the learner does some computation spits
out a hypothesis distribution and we
want with high confidence right with the
small failure probability the hypothesis
distribution to be close to the target
distribution and people mostly study
this with this fairly stringent
total variation distance measure l1
distance between the two distributions
okay
so this slide just has two toy examples
of results um on learning distribution
so here's a one-dimensional example you
could think about learning this class c
of all k modal distributions over
universe of
n elements okay so k modal means k peaks
and valleys if you were to draw sort of
the plot of the uh the probability
density function okay we have quite
efficient algorithms for learning uh
this class these algorithms actually run
in close to linear time i'm hiding some
log factors here so this
slide is not 100 honest but the
algorithm's running close to linear time
in the sample complexity and the sample
complexity is known to be optimal
so in one dimension sometimes we can get
these very strong results where we know
the exact information theoretic correct
sample complexity and we also are able
to come up with algorithms which run in
really the right amount of time as well
in high dimensions things get a lot
harder so this is a cartoon picture of a
mixture of three one-dimensional
gaussians i'm not enough of an artist to
draw a mixture of n-dimensional
gaussians but you know in very
impressive work it has been shown how to
learn mixtures of say k gaussians over n
dimensions and these are arbitrary
gaussians they don't have to be axis
aligned or anything
in polynomial time at least as long as
the number k is constant okay
so these are examples of sort of basic
results analogous to what i was saying
about conjunctions and linear threshold
functions and decision lists and so on
for the distribution learning problem we
don't have a notion of noise we don't
have a notion of missing data but of
course we want those notions right so
how do we sort of cook noise into the
picture well we can have this notion of
agnostically learning distributions
which again is defined entirely
analogously to agnostically learning
classification rules or boolean
functions the distribution is now
assumed to be arbitrary
right we have this notion of opt being
the minimum distance from the arbitrary
target to a distribution in our class
and we'd like to come up with a
hypothesis distribution h whoops sorry
this should be an h instead of a d prime
we want a hypothesis distribution whose
error is at most off plus epsilon or
maybe 5 i plus epsilon or so on and so
forth so the same kind of notion of
doing as well as the best distribution
in our class and i'll close by just
telling you about
two results on
agnostic or quasi-agnostic learning of
probability distributions
so this is a one-dimensional problem
okay we're going to consider this class
of t piecewise degree d polynomial
distributions so they're distributions
over some segment of the real line and
here t would be four d would be three
right this is some wacky distribution
where within each of these four pieces
the probability mass function is a
degree d degree 3 polynomial
okay
so it's known how to agnostically learn
this class of distributions or i should
really say quasi-agnostically it's three
opt plus epsilon is what's achieved and
the latest result done with some
impressive algorithmic machinery
runs in again essentially linear time
in the number of samples so the number
of samples is this the running time is
essentially this i'm hiding a log factor
again and this is also an information
theoretic lower bound you need this many
examples no matter how
slowly your algorithm is allowed to run
okay and this turns out to be useful
because if you can
achieve this kind of agnostic or
quasi-agnostic learning you can use this
as sort of a subroutine to get learning
results for many different classes of
distributions that people have studied
you prove a structural result saying hey
you're interested in log concave
distributions actually they can be well
approximated by distributions like this
and then the sort of quasi-agnostic
guarantee tells you that the
approximation is enough you can
successfully learn the distribution
which is being approximated okay so kind
of a one-dimensional example and i'll
make this my last slide a very recent
work that'll be in the upcoming fox
conference the first work really on high
dimensional
almost agnostic quasi-agnostic
distribution learning
so the classes of distributions that are
being learned here they're over n
dimensions they may not look that
complicated or that impressive right
you're trying to learn a single
n-dimensional gaussian or you're trying
to learn a single n-dimensional product
distribution over the cube neither of
these are hard learning problems if you
have no noise if you have no noise for
the gaussian i'll just learn the
covariance matrix by sampling i'll learn
the mean by sampling and i'll spit out
those parameters and i'll have a high
accuracy hypothesis for the product
distribution if you have no noise i'll
just estimate the probability that the
first coordinate is 1 the second
coordinate is 1 so on and so forth these
are easy learning problems if there's no
noise if you're in high dimension and
there is noise it's very very
non-trivial to learn these classes it's
easy to learn these classes if you're
willing to have something like n times
opt as your error rate or square root n
times opt as your error rate if you want
to get an error rate which is completely
independent of the dimension that's much
more difficult to do it was only
achieved you know very recently in this
upcoming paper and you can see that at
least for say learning a single gaussian
it's really very good right they only
have a small
kind of additional factor above opth
plus epsilon which is sort of the ideal
thing you would want and the result is a
little um
a little harder for uh product
distributions okay
so you know we're really at the point
now where the community is just starting
to make progress on these agnostic or
quasi-agnostic high-dimensional
distribution learning problems and my
guess is there's going to be a lot of
future work along these lines
i had one slide on learning
distributions from partial information
but since i'm a little bit over time
maybe i'll just cut to the conclusion
the summary is that we've talked about a
range of different models and results
for learning from noisy and incomplete
data there are a lot of interesting
algorithmic challenges and i should have
given this apology at the beginning of
the talk i'll give it now at the end of
the talk which is
really very little is known and it's not
because i'm hiding it from you just the
community doesn't really understand very
much about what can be done
say in a streaming setting in a
real-time setting even achieving linear
time as we saw is quite a challenge for
most of these problems we often have
polynomial time or even something which
you have to be sort of in a good mood to
call polynomial time for a lot of these
problems
so i think there's a lot of work to be
done in terms of trying to get
stronger results which would maybe
adhere more closely to the kinds of
settings that we in this room are
interested in
okay thanks
what's up here so diagnostic selling is
there anything that can be there in
relation to coding theory but
if you think of the the concept classes
consisting of code words or something
like that so any example you see cannot
be too close to two of them
or something is there any kind of
connection of that kind
that's an interesting point of view on
it i'm not nothing comes to mind yeah
i don't know of anything
i wake up in the middle of the night and
realize oh yeah that doesn't such i'll
send you an email but off the top of the
top of my head i can't i'm not coming up
with any connections yeah
what's the connection of the image
oh it's just uh
yeah i guess maybe implicitly you guys
are the cow or something i'm
not really sure this is a mark it's a
mark tansy painting um they used to have
it in the mat it's i've been fond of it
for a while yeah
it's called the innocent eye test so
yeah
and i think that's a monet haystack in
the background
i understand